[Music]  okay no medical stuff  oh she who made the anime who came to  visit us in production to see that world  imagine it's pretty spectacular scale of  it is so baked in from the beginning  it's very true that anime Roberta is  really a visionary it's called she's  incredible it's great to start from  something that inspires you  this experience has been like nothing  else I've ever had before  storytellers and the multiple photos the  segment intimately  because also says you lucky not to do  another strategy it's not acceptable we  created a universe that people haven't  seen before  [Music]  [Music]  what are you  [Music]  [Music]  this is just the beginning yes I am a  dancer Cory is not you just need to find  a woman who is pathetic like you thanks  buddy do you need a hug